alright prepare not only are you great  at what you do every single night on  special report but I know you I know the  person I know your family I know your  kids and 10 wonderful successful years  you're only 13 years behind me so you  got a little bit of catching up to do  but we are proud of you congratulations  for all your great success and the  wonderful job you do informing people  each and every night right here on the  Fox News Channel I swear to you it seems  like yesterday that you took over as the  head of the helm of special report  welcome to Washington I'm Bret Baier for  ten years brought you've done a  fantastic job leading their way breaking  news top interviews your work ethic and  your commitment to detail and getting  things right  is it example for all of us  congratulations on 10 years here's to  many more